I have to wonder how many people are
gonna get what I mean when I say the
movie isn't stupid enough
[Music]
Jurassic world fallen Kingdom this one
is overdue but I only recently got
around to seeing the movie and to that
one commenter kept saying that they
disliked every video because I hadn't
reviewed it yet I was very tempted to
never review just despite you don't
harass me to do stuff you make me want
to not ever do it but I've seen the
movie so I might as well to get a video
out of it even if nobody probably cares
anymore so Jurassic world falling
Kingdom I suppose a little bit of
context cuz I didn't do a review of the
first Jurassic world movie or any of the
Jurassic Park films Jurassic Park is a
classic it's oddly not quite as seminal
to my childhood as it is to a lot of
people my age like I saw it in the
theater it was awesome I loved it but I
wasn't I didn't have the life-changing
mind-blowing experience a lot of people
my age seem to have gotten in the
theater I don't know why not maybe
because I watched a heck of a lot of
dinosaur stuff already yes these were
the best looking dinosaurs but I knew
what dinosaurs looked like though it's
just looked like really good ones I
don't know um but in case the original
is a classic it still holds up
everything else has been varying degrees
of not very good
Jurassic world was stupid fun it was a
little bit stupider than I think it it
probably should have been and that might
sound weird given how I opened this
whole review but I will get to that I
will explain that hopefully a little bit
better so there are gonna be spoilers
yeah and they're probably gonna start
coming kind of early this is a movie
that's been out long enough that I don't
feel like I need to restrain them but
before I get into spoilers
broadly speaking my big issue with the
film is that it plays almost entirely
like a remake of the lost world with
some very
minor tweaks like adding a volcano like
almost beat for beat in a lot of ways
and I'll get into details in a second
but it's just there are moments that are
fun very fun but they are the exception
rather than the rule so getting into
spoilers in terms of making the
comparison to Jurassic Park the lost
world well let's see
it is an island full of dinosaurs some
people from the previous movie go there
there is a team of not particularly nice
people capturing the dinosaurs there is
a great white hunter style character the
film can very neatly be divided into two
sections one on the island one off the
island and off the island involves
improperly housing these dinosaurs and
using them for stupid corporate greed
schemes yeah and somehow there's a kid
again why is that why are there kids in
every single one of these movies I got
it the first time because you know kids
were part of the target audience every
single time after that though they have
been so shoehorned in and that's the
case here as well although they do one
slightly interesting thing with the kid
that feels more like a tossed off notion
of what could have been and maybe is an
indication that maybe the next one will
be dumb in the way I want to be done so
to come back to my original statement I
found myself thinking I wish this was
stupider I wish this wasn't trying to
still be serious and that's partly
that's the problem of the pedigree
because that original film is still so
good that I can I still sense a
reluctance on the parts of these
filmmakers to abandon that and go as
walkie as the franchise should be at
this point like it's easy to point at
something like fasten the furies thing
go look you should have embraced
insanity the way that series did but the
thing is fast in the Furious while it
had its fans prior to be
coming more of what it is now nobody
ever called any of the original three
movies or so classics
so that was revamping something that was
fine into something a lot more fun
they're still trying to cling to what
has been lost ever since the very first
film and they needs to stop they need to
embrace how dumb this is cuz this is
really dumb and they really need to stop
with drying for poignancy points and
having shots like that Brachiosaurus the
smoking golf sim and it clearly dies in
a fire thingy and yo characters are
crying they're going for poignancy boys
like I actually leaned over the person I
went to the movie went and went somebody
didn't tell this movie that it's too
stupid to be able to pull off that
moment so I did keep having the thought
I was watching it should this be
stupider and not exactly it needs to be
stupid in different ways so I do enjoy
dumb fun movies there are many many
eighties action movies that qualifies
dumb fun like the heck many nineties
actual movies they call it fires
dumpling my quintessential dumb fun
movie is GI Joe Rise of Cobra oh it's so
stupid but man is it fun the way that
you avoid having a stupid fun movie
simply be stupid is the way in which
it's stupid so a dumb fun movie should
have stupid ideas
stupid concepts stupid set pieces what
you shouldn't have are characters who
behave stupidly and that's where things
fall apart here lots of these characters
do lots of things that are very very
very stupid both the heroes and the
villains couple of examples off atop my
head
you had Claire Bryce Dallas Howard back
and this annoying techie guy and they're
in this room this is on the this is
before the volcano blows up the island
at about the halfway mark I told you
there were gonna be spoilers so they are
in this room where they had you know
turned the dinosaur tracking back on so
they could find everybody they can find
blue the Raptor from previous movie
specifically but something goes wrong
and the door shut and they're stuck in
there and they managed to get some of
the doors open but the doors that they
managed to get open lead out into the
park which means there's now a I don't
I'm not sure what species it was but
there is some form of predatory dinosaur
coming at them and the lavas starting to
come in and now they're in big trouble
and in order to get out of there they
spot a ladder that leads to a hatch in a
way out and that is where the Clash of
the right kind of stupid clashes with
the wrong kind of suit because the right
kind of stupid is this big toothy
dinosaur stalking them trying to figure
out how to get through this like drippy
almost veil of falling lava that's the
right kind of stupid characters who were
trapped in a room and were fiddling with
this fiddly you know computer system
that they couldn't get to work and
didn't look around the room enough to
notice the ladder
prior to this situation that's the wrong
kind of stupid so and like I said heroes
and villains the villain oh my god is he
dumb allow me to say out loud my evil
scheme as I walk up to this keypad with
this huge brightly brightly lit numbers
on it so that somebody could be what do
you think back and see what code I'm
punching in that's the wrong kind of
stupid capturing the heroes agreeing
with your prime henchman that you should
kill them why and you have a gun right
there and you leave and leave them in
the cage instead of just killing them at
the point you decided that they should
probably die and it's better for you if
they do that's the wrong kind
stupid a child who has demonstrated a
knowledge of knowing how to get around
this very sizable house including some I
don't want to say secret ways but some
sneaky ways fleeing to her room to hide
under her bed covers that's the wrong
kind of stupid
a raptor skewering a monster dinosaur on
a try tara Triceratops skull that's the
right kind of stupid but it's this clash
there's too much of the wrong kind of
stupid that is butting up against the
right kind of stupid and I wit cuz this
thing is dabbling in the kind of idiocy
that I think the series just needs to
embrace at this point cuz it's never
gonna recapture the original needs to
lose any pretense of that and they
almost do here but they don't go far
enough so like we've got another
designer dinosaur and they there's like
a build-up to it they hold off its
reveal for a while and ultimately it
just looks like a smaller version of the
indominus rex slightly cooler coloring
i'll give it that but it doesn't look so
substantial he's different from the last
custom dinosaur you did
so all that build up didn't really feel
like much it feels like we're treading
in place and it extra feels like we're
treading in place because of how much of
a retread this was from the lost world
as far as overall plot goes now there
are a couple of interesting twist to
this the finding out that the
granddaughter is a clone that's a big
deal yeah and I feel like that here's
the level of stupid I wanted from this
movie and you can tell me this is dumb
and I know this is dumb but this is the
level I feel like this franchise needs
to go to it what I would have liked to
have found out was that she was a clone
of her mother or she was intended to be
but cloning humans has it isn't
something has been perfected yet they
only really truly know how to clone
dinosaurs really well so she is actually
a little bit of dinosaur DNA in her and
like we find out she I don't know kids
can see an infrared or something that's
the level of stupid I want this this
series to embrace and I feel like it's
tiptoeing it and I wanted to dive in at
this point I'm just gonna rattle off a
bunch of nitpicks all of which occurred
to me as the film was going along and
took me out of it and I will try to
avoid too many real-world things like
the fact that Chris Pratt was so damn
close to this lava it wouldn't have
mattered if it touched him he would've
you would have died from that heat
anyway let's set that aside and stuff
like that aside but you know things like
they made this big deal about hey and
this is just me going through complaints
at this point I've got nothing
substantive left but they make this this
whole thing about how they the dinosaurs
are gonna go extinct and they say they
saved 11 species but we only ever see
one of each of them and in the case of
blue the Raptor they do say she's the
last one and especially given the way
the film ends after the dinosaurs have
escaped and it kind of implies that
dinosaurs are now like loose in the
world again
they don't have breeding pairs and even
if they did one breeding pair just will
not repopulate a species that's one of
those that's that's one of those things
that does drive me crazy yes I know
Noah's Ark and all that but it's a
parable but in nature if you don't have
50 you then inbreeding alone is gonna
wipe them out in a couple of generations
and like I said most of these I didn't
even see pears I just saw one now if
they want to recover this for the
following one a way to go to the level
of stupid that I'd be willing to that I
go yes is tell me that these dinosaurs
because of the genetic engineering and
the tinkering that went on with them can
actually crossbreed which real dinosaurs
going to
you know a t-rex couldn't knock up an
ankylosaurus in real life but tell me
that these these called I know sores
these genetic monstrosities can and then
we get these crazy hybrid dinosaurs in
the in the next film that's awesome but
if you're not gonna do that then this is
just stupid don't so yeah you know what
I don't even have the energy to keep
running it well no I've got one more the
villain is so so stupid actually both of
them are both the the weaselly corporate
guy and the and his big game hunter he
just strolls in opens up the cage to
take a tooth because apparently he's
really into making a necklace a dinosaur
- what a freaking idiot and then this
guy this guy he's all excited about
making any makes more than this but
making like a hundred million dollars
and I'm looking at this underground
facility this three level underground
facility with fully functioning
high-tech cloning lab thinking to myself
I'm pretty sure if whatever resources
from this estate you skimmed into the
designing building maintaining and
staffing of your little underground lair
if you just funneled that straight into
your own account just straight-up
embezzled it you probably would have
made the same amount of money you're
dumb and and just as a total side note I
think we're now up to our fourth
eccentric millionaire with an obsession
with dinosaurs and that's not even
getting to how many friggin people were
in that bidding opposite yeah I was
prepared for this to be stupid but too
often it was the wrong kind of stupid so
those are my thoughts on Jurassic world
the fallen Kingdom there are there is
some fun to be had but boy you gotta be
willing to shut off pretty much all of
your higher brain functions have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it
stop to do so just like and subscribe
and follow me on Twitter and listen my
podcast support me on patreon that's the
big one
links for all that stuff is down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]